أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، ستنتقل من
أسطول مكون من 147 طائرة إلى 200 طائرة بحلول عام 2020 ،
وهذا مدفوع أساسًا بالنمو الداخلي
مع استيقاظ هذا السوق
لإمكاناته في الواقع ، فنحن نبني
على قوة السوق السعودي.
الكثير من
النمو داخليًا بالإضافة إلى وجود
خطة طموحة لتنمية
السياحة الدينية إلى المملكة العربية السعودية حيث
نستهدف 30 مليون ملليغرام حتى
عام 2030 في الواقع لقد كنت في البلاد
خمس مرات خلال العام الماضي ،
والبنية التحتية الجديدة الموجودة في  المكان عبارة
عن شبكات سكك حديدية عالية السرعة مثيرة للإعجاب
والباقي ، لكن من الضروري الحصول على
تأشيرة سياحية ، وبينما نراها
بحلول النصف الثاني من عام 2018
لإخراج الزوار الدوليين ،
هناك بالفعل ثلاث مبادرات رئيسية من
شأنها أن تجعل اللعبة-  المغير
لصناعة النقل في المملكة العربية السعودية
واحد هو البنية التحتية
والأهم بالنسبة لنا هو افتتاح
الطائرة الجديدة والمحطة الثانية هي
التحسين والمبسطة  إن برنامج
عمليات التأشيرة الثالث هو البرنامج الخمسة الأوائل
الذي نطلقه داخل
شركة الطيران لتحسين الخدمة من
البداية إلى النهاية الرائعة التي ترتبط بها
في شركة النقل منخفضة التكلفة وذلك لتعزيز
النمو الداخلي وحركة المرور العابر
القادمة  إلى المملكة العربية السعودية أيضًا ، إنها
ثورة عندما يتعلق الأمر بالسوق
نفسه ، فليس من المؤكد
أننا أطلقنا ميزة fly في شركة الطيران
منخفضة التكلفة الخاصة بنا خلال آخر
يوم وطني لنا في 23 سبتمبر 2017 ، لقد كانت
بداية قوية جدًا اليوم  تشغل فلاي عديل
44 رحلة في اليوم إلى 7 مدن
داخل المملكة العربية السعودية والمدينة التالية
ستنطلق في 3 مايو إلى
تبوك وستستمر في التوسع
تدريجياً والهدف هو التوسع في
حركة المرور المحلية وإقليمياً وكذلك
على المستوى الدولي.  المشاهدين لا أعتقد
أنهم سيفهمون أنه من بين 27
مطارًا إقليميًا في المملكة العربية السعودية ، يتم تجديد 20 مطارًا منها
حاليًا بأكثر من
7 مليارات دولار تم إنفاقها على جينا ، هذه
دفعة حقيقية من التاج.  الأمير محمد
بن سلمان لدفع هذا باعتباره
مكونًا رئيسيًا للنمو الاقتصادي ،
هناك بالتأكيد استثمار ضخم مستمر ،
وهناك انقسام يعمل على محاذاة الجميع
نحو هدف واحد ، مما يخلق الكثير من
الزخم فيما يتعلق بالبنية
التحتية ، فالمحطة هي الأهم
بالنسبة لنا ولكن  هناك أيضًا 20
مطارًا آخر يتم تجديدها كما تعلم أن
الخطوط الجوية السعودية تخدم 27 مطارًا محليًا
كل يوم ، إنه لأمر رائع أنك تريد أن
يتم تصنيفك في أفضل شركات النقل من فئة الخمس نجوم ،
نعم في المستقبل هذه الواقعية نحن
متفائلون جدًا بشأن تحقيق هذا
الهدف الذي بدأناه  قبل عامين
لتجديد شركة الطيران بأكملها ، قمنا
بتغيير الخدمة التي نقوم بتحسين المنتج بها ،
ونعمل على تعزيز جميع الأنشطة ، وقد
أطلقنا للتو مبادرة جديدة أكثر
طموحًا لنكون في المرتبة الأولى
من بين شركات الطيران ذات الخمس نجوم في العالم
بنهاية  لعام 2019